this impressive upload is brighten the
lives of 400,000 people it shows
cutting-edge Dutch scientists driving a
solar-powered car called stellar across
Australia in the 2013 World Solar
Challenge I think we're seeing the
future here with a family solar car I
could imagine using this I'd love to
take it for a road trip around Australia
1860 solar powered miles later they won
the challenge and the Internet we caught
up with Lex hoops lute the stellar teams
leader in Eindhoven and in Netherlands
me my friend we had the idea to start a
team and to make this car just one year
we were able to design build and test
and race the car in Australia we
expected it to be quite fast like 70
days in our ATK's an hour and then
actually during the race we have been
able to drive 120 kilometres an hour
we got a ride for life to see how
stellar performed and got stuck in a
traffic jam
nice thing about being stuck in the
traffic jam with this car is that you
gain more energy so the range is
increasing while you're sitting in the
car so how does teller fill up on the
sun's power this car works by taking
sunlight into its solar panels and
converting that light energy into
electrical energy which it used to drive
the car how do the solar panels in the
car work we have a base material silica
and when you add different atoms to
silicon called doping you can make it an
n-type or a p-type silicon and types
have extra electrons P types have a
deficiency in electrons at the junction
between these two layers electrons from
the electron rich area migrate to the
other area and create a depletion zone
and no more electrons can go between
them the depletion zone means there's a
gap in the circuit so electrons can't
flow around to charge the battery what
is sunlight do when it hits the silicon
sandwich the light ends up being
absorbed by electrons which are then
smashed off of their atoms and that
given enough energy to travel through
the depletion zone over to the n-type
semiconductor where they can then pass
back around the circuit keeping our
current going it's free energy it's good
for the environment it's awesome Stella
the car that runs on Sun power